ahora
a pocas semanas de las elecciones más
polarizadas de su historia reciente
brasil vivió un intenso clima de
precampaña
este país tiene que amar los libros y no
las armas este país tiene que anteponer
el amor al odio
[Aplausos]
en julio los dos principales rivales
luiz inácio lula da silva y jair
bolsonaro se dieron un baño de masas en
río de janeiro
convoco a todos ustedes ahora para que
todo el mundo del 7 de septiembre vaya a
las calles por última vez
[Aplausos]
[Música]
sin embargo la violencia ha enturbiado
el escenario político en este acto de
lula el 7 de julio lanzaron un artefacto
explosivo con heces que hirió levemente
a una mujer dos días después en el sur
de brasil fue asesinado a tiros el
tesorero del partido de los trabajadores
la formación política fundada por lula
el asesino disparó al grito de aquí es
bolsonaro
el 16 de julio algunos precandidatos de
izquierda al gobierno de río de janeiro
fueron agredidos por un diputado de
derecha durante una manifestación contra
el reciente atentado político
conmigo
una semana después los mismos militantes
volvieron a protestar en la calle nos ha
preparado el sábado pasado aquí hubo una
agresión
[Música]
vivimos uno de los momentos más
difíciles de nuestra historia
este abogado de derechos humanos
denunció la agresión a la policía relata
que hubo empujones y que destruyeron sus
banderas
cualquier persona que esté comprometida
con el proceso de civilización en brásil
con la democracia con el estado
democrático de derecho sólo tiene una
opción elegir a lula como presidente en
octubre es nula o la barbarie si
bolsonaro hoy se mantiene en el poder la
posibilidad de que se practique la
violencia contra quien piensa de forma
diferente será aún más grande el
presidente de brasil negó cualquier
responsabilidad tras ser acusado de
incitar a la violencia con sus discursos
provocadores
dios mío mi discurso llevó a la muerte
de aquella persona fue una pelea
estúpida sin razón
los seguidores de bolsonaro respaldan
las palabras de su líder
hoy es el día del desfile en motocicleta
una tradición lanzada el año pasado por
bolsonaro en todo el país
estamos en la bajada fluminense en el
extrarradio del río de janeiro donde
viven muchos militares activos o en la
reserva
este es charles batista un precandidato
evolución arista el descarta que en los
próximos meses pueda producirse una
escalada de la violencia
la principal estrategia de nuestros
adversarios de la izquierda es a
cruzarnos de lo que ellos hacen vamos a
mantener la sobriedad hacer una campaña
limpia y dejar que el pueblo escoja
entre los partidarios de bolsonaro hay
muchos ex votantes de lula que se
decepcionaron por el camino
hasta 2016 siempre fui el partido de los
trabajadores siempre vote a este partido
pero no estaba bien informado en aquella
época no teníamos esto hoy tenemos la
tecnología
reencontramos andrew una semana después
en el acto de lanzamiento de la
candidatura de bolsonaro
es mucha emoción
bolsonaro dice lo que necesitamos oír
dice la verdad él defiende la verdad
defiende a la familia yo dejé a mis
hijos y a mis sobrinos en casa para
estar aquí yo voy a luchar también por
ellos
a medida que se acercan las elecciones
el discurso de audio aumenta en las
redes sociales y un uso a favor de
violencia más aún persiste pienso el de
esto es que esto me llevo a mi familia
pues prepara se va en contra el cid el
plano infierno cambadés field apunta
este simpatizante del mandatario
brasileño fue arrestado tras amenazar a
lula y a varios jueces de la corte
suprema
mientras tanto en río de janeiro ha
estallado la guerra de las toallas este
puesto callejero se ha convertido en una
arena de confrontación política este
barrio es de izquierda entonces dado que
tengo toalla de los dos candidatos hay
muchas discusiones incluso con
palabrotas y ofensas que nos hacen
bromas pero otros se lo toman muy en
serio la fiebre de las toallas ha
contagiado a los cariocas a juzgar por
las ventas lula sería el ganador pero
aún queda un largo camino hasta las
elecciones